everybody i have cared for
has either died
or left me
you have no idea what loss is
[Applause]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and who else is here for
the last of us teaser trailer little
golf joke there and i tell you we can
look back and laugh now but at the time
dear me anyway the new show looks
incredible and throughout this video i
want to go through the trailer frame by
frame and talk about all the details in
it there will be some major spoilers
here in terms of what happens in the
game though so if you haven't checked it
out then check out now if you enjoyed
the video please hit the thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day by the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the last of us
[Music]
okay so the teaser opens in winter with
joel and ellie crossing a bridge this
instantly lets us know that things will
be changed from the original game as
though the setting is the same the
circumstances aren't the entire first
game took place roughly over the space
of the air with us getting several
seasons all denoting certain themes and
time periods during this point in the
original release joel was actually
recovering from falling on some rebar
and ellie was out hunting for medicine
and food whilst he was resting up here
she came across david who seemed like a
good samaritan that was just trying to
help her out you know the kind of guy
who always likes and subscribes he was
however revealed to be the leader of a
group of cannibals and he was probably
also a nuns in the series he will be
played by con o'neal so i am expecting
him to show up here now ellie ended up
not only biting him but she also
eventually stabbed him with his
switchblade which we see her carrying in
the first look now in case you haven't
played the games which why not they're
great the entire world is in this state
because the quarter set fungi has
mutated and found a way to pass itself
onto humans this turned them into crazed
zombies desperate to bite others and
pass on the infection if you came across
them you'd often find them sobbing and
weeping because they were sent into a
painful feral state that they were
unable to escape from the infection only
got worse as well and over time they
transformed into clickers which were
terrifying blind zombies that preyed on
sound all of civilization collapsed but
there came some hope in ellie who was
actually immune to the infection hired
by a group known as the fireflies joel
was tasked with transporting her across
the country and though he initially took
a dislike to her over time the pair
bonded this is because joel very much
saw an ally the daughter that he lost on
the first night of the outbreak sarah
was killed by a triggerfinger happy
member of the government and since then
joel has walked down a dark path in
order to make sure he keeps surviving at
one point in the teaser we see sarah
being carried by joel as he runs through
his stall played by nico parker i don't
think she'll stick around long and this
will probably be how the first episode
begins the carrying of her is clearly
set up to be just like how it was in the
first game and having her like this
actually stopped girl from getting shot
because she took the bullets now we get
two shots of her with the first being
carried in front exactly like how it
played out in the prelude to the main
story ellie says everyone she's ever
known has either left or died whilst
joel says she has no idea what loss is
clearly referring to the death of his
daughter the story is very much about
ellie learning to trust again whilst for
joel it's very much about him opening
himself up it's made difficult early on
by the death of tess who will be played
by anatov in the show he's very much
just out for himself constantly set on
making it through the next day but ellie
gives him something to live for and also
care about now initially it might seem
like we don't see any infected in the
trailer the closest tees we get to one
happens when we have brief flash's
valley running whilst firing backwards
according back to the game we can catch
the rundown cars that have been picked
apart and also left to rot i think this
might actually be pittsburgh and the
game featured a scene in which the pair
were chased at night through the streets
by an armored car we actually get the
same setup to that level in a shot in
which the pair both look in the wing
mirror of their car similar to how the
trip to the city began the pair were
ambushed and they ended up having to
leave their ride and then travel through
the concrete jungle whilst they were
hunted so this could just end up being
ellie and joel trying to escape from the
people that lived there and it might not
even be the infected chasing after her
however we do get at least one when we
see the shot of some fungus on the wall
if you look closely in it you can
actually see that there's a person there
with fungus coming out of them typically
when someone mutated past a certain
point their body ended up becoming
overrun with the cordyceps and they lay
down somewhere and died they then spread
out like a plant into their surroundings
and they fired spores into the air that
had the power to infect someone normally
people would wear gas masks to stop them
breathing it in but we see ellie doesn't
need one because she's immune now sites
like this were commonplace throughout
the game environment and i love how
similar it looks to something you'd find
in it the green brick wall is exactly
like how it is in the original even down
to the coloring which is some really
nice attention to detail don't think
i've seen that green anywhere else
either on a wolf so
nice bit of decoration there now it took
years for someone to end up like this
and we actually have a possible time
period for when the world fell apart at
one point we see joel giving ellie a gun
which was a big moment in the game this
was handed over to hail right after the
hotel mission in pittsburgh and it was
modeled after a beretta 70 series i
think this will be the case here as we
can catch a newspaper behind her which
has kansas city written on it now back
to the date when everything fell apart
we can see that the paper is reporting
the cost of the iraq war this likely
means that everything fell apart in the
mid to late 2000s the original game took
place in 2033 but the creative team have
said that they're shifting things back
10 years and placing this in 2023 so it
feels a bit more current for viewers we
also don't know for definite how many
seasons that the series will go for but
i'm kind of hoping that they pump the
brakes a bit and give us several in the
first game and then several in the
second i'm guessing everyone knows about
the big death at the start of two and
i'm kind of hoping that pascal sticks
around for a couple of years the games
take a while to develop too and it's
likely that the series would end up
passing the events of the source
material if they were doing just one
season per game now lastly we see bill
being played by nick offerman he looks
exactly like the character and has not
only his facial hair but also his gas
mask and shotgun shells bill had made a
home for himself in lincoln
massachusetts and he'd outfitted the
town with booby traps he was an old pile
of jewels and he helped them through the
city whilst he also looked for his lover
who ended up leaving with him great to
see offerman in the show and it feels
like perfect casting for bill he was
somewhat of a recluse who had clearly
gone through a lot of heartbreak like
joel had and i can't expect to see him
showing up early on this also solidifies
that the series will take place in
multiple cities with multiple seasons
i'm guessing that bill's point is in the
spring they end that by getting the car
then travel to pittsburgh which will
take place in the summer the fall will
likely be at the university and the
winter will be with david they might
even pace it so that's the final arc and
with joel being okay at this point in
the show david could be the one who ends
up damaging him i don't know how it's
gonna go down but what i do know is that
this was a very short but sweet teaser
it's not really much to go off but the
small segments that we do have look a
lot like the game even down to joel's
shirt we have them clearly paying
respect to the source material which i
think is a really good thing the series
is rumored to premiere at the end of the
year and i think it would be a great way
to close things out if it hits that date
hbo always gets the best of the best of
the best so when it comes to writing and
i think this might close out the air on
a high very excited to see where they're
gonna go with it and obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the first look
below as a thank you you'll be entered
into a competition where we're giving
away three copies of top gun maverick on
the 15th of september all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of house of the dragon which
will be linked on the screen right now
we go over all the characters in it
everything you need to know about them
without giving away too many too many
spoilers and there yeah definitely go
check it out right after this by the way
thanks for sitting through the video
i've been paul let's see in the next one
take care peace